at this shopping mall in Beijing people
take a few moments to stop and listen to
the Chinese president's New Year Speech
Xi Jinping appealed for Unity as his
administration faces criticism at home
for its handling of coronavirus
China is so big a country different
people will have different demands and
different views on the same thing which
is normal it is necessary to build
consensus through communication and
consultation this small would normally
have been packed on New Year's Eve but
infections have surged since the
government abruptly reversed its zero
covert policy and that's put a damper on
celebrations
[Music]
I hope the pandemic goes away in 2023
and the country goes back to normal
I stayed at home the whole of last year
the pandemic is horrible I hope I don't
have to stay at home this new year in
Hong Kong the mood is decidedly
different nearly all covet requirements
were removed on Thursday people are out
to party and hoping for a better year
ahead
bring Hong Kong back
we hope that Hong Kong is going to be
back to its former glory well I hope
covet goes away earlier because it's
affecting everybody so yeah
the only indication covet is still a
concern here are these face masks are
mandatory in all public spaces even
Outdoors but while China and Hong Kong
have relaxed covet rules other countries
are fearful of another wave of
infections and have placed restrictions
on visitors from these places
and some health experts say the
increased cases in China could lead to
the development of new variants of the
virus
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Hong Kong